(Norman imite un mouton) Mêh mêh mêh mêh mêh
Bonjour à tous ! Alors je vous présente le premier épisode de "Presque Adultes"
Une mini-série qu'on a écrite avec Cyprien, Julien Josselin
Et Flobert, entre potos du net quoi
J'suis content parce que TF1 et Fanta qui financent le projet
ont complètement accepté nos scénarios sans jamais rien modifier.
Du coup on a pu faire absolument ce qu'on voulait de manière libre
Hm, c'est 100% nous !
Même si cette mini-série est aussi diffusée à la télé, euh...On n'est pas racheté par la télé,
on ne se met pas à faire de la télé,
on va pas commencer à présenter la météo demain, à TF1
Je vous rassure.
C'est juste un petit projet artistique qui en plus d'être diffusé sur Youtube, est aussi diffusé à la télé une fois.
Voilà c'est tout !
Alors attention, ceux qui s'attendent à voir une vidéo Youtube avec pleins de blagues toutes les trois secondes,
*cris étranges et coups de feu* Bonjour, je suis un personnage de podcasts.. :) *boing*
Et ben ,c'est pas du tout ça, hein, des vidéos comme ça, y'en a plein sur ma chaîne youtube
Et y'en aura encore plein.
Là, "Presque Adultes" c'est autre chose, c'est une mini série où on essaye de raconter des histoires
un peu plus sur la longueur, un peu plus sérieusement,
mais pas trop non plus. Dans 'Presque adultes' on parle du concept d'être adulte
Qui est un concept un petit peu abstrait parce que
qui peux réellement prétendre être adulte, en fait ?
Hein ?J'vous le demande, madame !
[La dame] J'EN SAIS RIEN DU TOUT !
[Norman] MAIS VOILA FERME TA GUEU..
Ce premier épisode, que je vais vous montrer là, tout de suite, dans quelques secondes,
Parle du fait d'assumer ses parents, de pas les oublier
Surtout quand ils commencent un petit peu à vieillir...
D'ailleurs, celui-ci est entièremment inspiré de mon vrai papa
Et d'ailleurs, je lui dédicace
Alors ce premier épisode fait parti d'une suite de 10 épisodes
qui se répondent les uns aux autres, du coup, je vous recommande de
tout regarder pour vraiment bien apprécier le délire.
Et selon moi,
les meilleurs épisodes, sont les derniers, hein, donc j'vais pas spoiler
Mais j'meurs à la fin.
FAUX
Alors, je n'arrête pas mes vidéos YouTube pour ne faire que "Presque Adultes"
Hein, je continue mes vidéos Youtube comme d'habitude
Et "Presque Adultes" ben c'est un petit projet parallèle supplémentaire avec mes potes
Ca fait toujours plaisir de faire un petit peu de nouveauté surtout pour l'été
Et pour ceux qui préfèrent tout simplement mes vidéos Youtube habituelles
Eh ben, j'vous rassure y'en a plein qui vont arriver très bientôt !
Et d'ailleurs, soyez prêts parce que ça arrive à la vitesse de la lumière
"Presque Adultes" est diffusé tous les samedis soir à 20h45
à la télé, mais pour ceux qui préfèrent regarder sur Youtube
Y'en aura : trois sur ma chaîne
Trois sur celle de Natoo
Et, quatre sur celle de Cyprien.
Y'a clairement du favoritisme..
Merci d'avoir regardé cette introduction,
j'espère qu'elle était pas trop chiante.
Mettez un p'tit "TUMB TO THE TOP" pour nous soutenir
Et je vous laisse, avec le premier épisode, TCHAO (sous titres d'introduction par Light)
Mais mec,  ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on n'est pas venu ici
Tu vois cette arbre je le connais depuis 29 ans
Norman, je reconnais ta maison là
à droite ?
Exactement c'est là
- Ok j'arrive dans 5 minutes.
- Mais t'es sûr qu'il est là au moins ton père ?
Bah oui il a envoyé un texto je crois
Oui point tu point peux point passer
Ouais il a jamais trouvé la touche espace sur ses téléphones
Ok, à tout suite
Non non, vous vous ne bougez pas, vous restez ici j'y vais tout seul. Ok tranquille ?
Allez à tout suite
Norman s'est pris son premier râteau devant cette arbre
Être adulte c'est aussi ne pas oublier ceux qui nous on fait
(rire) Trop bien cette photo j'avais oublié. Julie et toi, première étoile
Bon alors je l'ai mis où ? Je crois que je l'avais mis là.
- T'enlèves pas ton manteau ?
- Non je reste pas
longtemps, je prends juste mon carnet de santé et après je file, j'ai pas le temps
J'espérais que, pour une fois, tu venais simplement saluer ton vieux père
Ouais mais je viens aussi te rendre visite un petit peu. Je fais d'une pierre deux coups
Le carnet de santé puis (rire)
Ça va toi ?
Ouais doucement
- Dans deux ans à la retraite quoi.
- Putain ça va vite
Eh ouais mais tant mieux j'ai envie de renouveau
Tu vois, j'ai envie de faire un petit potager dans le jardin
Petites carottes, petits pois, petits navets...
Ou alors
je vais carrément m'installer au Kenya !
D'accord. Bah commence déjà par le potage puis après on verra non ?
Et toi alors la vie ça va ? Ça se passe bien sur youbitube ?
Oh regarde y'a un vide grenier
- Eh vas-y viens on y va ?
- Oooh non c'est nul y'a que des vieux et des meubles
(rire)
Et des parents qui revendent les vieilles cartouches Pokémon de leurs gosses !
Ton carnet de santé, où est-ce que je l'ai foutu ?
Oh bah je te les donne, si tu veux
Tu sais je crois qu'à mon âge je n'en ferai plus jamais...
- Ah bah non c'est vrai que toi tu fais du monoski un peu bizarre.
- Ça s'appelle du snowboard
Oooh ma caisse de souvenir de quand j'étais petit .T'as tout gardé c'est trop mignon
Ah bah non c'est...
c'est pas à moi ça. C'est autre chose
Ouais bah tes affaires je les ai gardées
...fin bon jusqu'à ce que je les donne.
A qui ?
Bon ok à la poubelle
T'as raison, faut passer à autre chose dans la vie, faut tourner la page
Merci pour ça et puis à la prochaine !
C'est dommage que tu restes pas plus longtemps, on se voit une fois tous les 3 mois et ça dure 5 minutes
Ouais mais faut que j'y aille, j'ai mes amis qui m'attendent dans la voiture
- Oh bonjour les enfants.
- Bonjour M.Thavaud
C'est quoi, ce style ?
Bah on a trouvé ça au vide grenier. Stylé ou pas ?
D'accord.
Et moi j'ai trouvé des 45 tours bon j'ai rien pour les lires
- ... mais les pochettes sont canons.
-Tema la game gear
10 balles mais il me faut 16 piles .
Ok bah on verra ça une autre fois et on y va nous...
Mais je le reconnais lui, c'est le petit Cyprien !
Celui qui mangeait ses crottes de nez .
Ouais voilà c'est ça.
Nous faut qu'on y aille en tout cas
J'ai arrêté depuis hein...
Bon on va y aller, on y va.
Eh ! Vous rentrez prendre une petite binouze quand même !
Nan s'te plaît
5 minutes !
Nan nan nan nan nan, c'est pas possible !
Juste 5 minutes !
Pas de binouze !
Et la maman de Norman, elle se réveille un beau matin en disant qu'elle a fait un rêve prémonitoire
elle me dit qu'elle a entendu des voix qui lui disait qu'il fallait qu'elle fasse un enfant, là tout de suite maintenant.
Alors moi, si tu veux j'ai entendu ça je me suis dit "cool...
... je vais pouvoir tirer un petit coup, c'est pas de refus."
Et alors on a commencé... *bruits bizarres du père*
Bon bah ça va, on a compris l'histoire là ! On a compris.....
Et c'est comme ça qu'elle est tombée enceinte de Norman !
- Super * applaudissements*
- Bravo !
- Magnifique histoire
C'est une très belle histoire... que j'aurai aimé ne jamais connaître.
Oooooh
Attendez...
C'est Norman là ?
Bah oui ! Regardez comme il est beau là, avec sa petite tête de vainqueur
Ah ouais ! Sauf que c'est pas moi.
Ça c'est Florent Bernard. Moi je suis à côté ici
ah bon, ah bah j'ai toujours cru que c'était toi
et toi alors, quand est-ce que tu nous ramène une belle black ?
bah, j'sais pas, black on s'en fout, n'importe quel type de femme
j'ai pas de copine, donc voilà.
- t'aimes pas les blacks ?
- aucun rapport
-t'es pas raciste j'espère !
-n'importe quoi
- j't'ai pas élevé comme ça hein!
-*souffle*
ah j'y pense, j'ai quelque chose pour vous, bougez pas, je reviens
Bon, désolé, j'ai totalement honte de mon père, il est en train de m'afficher depuis tout à l'heure
- N'importe quoi, il est trop marrant ton père, il est génial
- mais grave !
vous dites ça parce que vous êtes bourrés
*rire*
bon ça joue mais il est vraiment cool en vrai
j'ai vu que t'avais des 45 tours
- génial !
-oh j'm'en rappelle, elle marche encore ?
ah ouais, elle marche, mais j'allais la bazarder, je m'en sers plus
Attends papa, faut arrêter de jeter tous les souvenirs de la vie comme ça, bêtement à la poubelle
c'est trop triste !
C'est idiot de conserver les trucs là
t'sais quoi ? garde là !
comme ça la prochaine fois que je viens,
j'ramène des vinyles et on les écoute ensemble
d'accord Norman
ah puis comme ça, tu pourras m'aider à tailler la haie
parce que moi, j'y arrive plus tout seul
- ok
ah, et puis y'a la cave à vider aussi, si tu pouvais
- je vais la brancher
pendant que j'y pense, tiens, y'a plein de feuilles dans les gouttières aussi
bon, qui veut écouter un peu de musique, hein ?
(Cyprien : c'est parti !)
Musique
*sonnerie hennissement de cheval*
ah ! ça doit être mon père qui doit nous envoyer un message pour nous remercier d'être passés
effectivement c'est bien lui, oui
il nous a envoyé un message vide
non, je pense qu'il a enfin trouvé la touche "espace"
Musique
(sous-titres par Light et Floou et correction par Bastiano34)